well parts of Northern California are
coping with the worst flooding there in
more than two decades floodwaters
carried away vehicles in the resort town
of Guerneville north of San Francisco
thousands of people are trapped by the
Russian rivers flooding National Guard
trucks are taking people to safety take
a look at this hotel pool before the
storm hit well now the whole property
looks more like a lake unbelievable
footage Meg Oliver is in Forestville
California in an area cut off by the
flooding Meg good morning good morning
we've been trapped here since yesterday
and will be stuck until the roads
reopened which could happen later today
the Russian River crested last night at
45 feet 13 feet over flood stage the
river has risen so high we won't know
the full extent of the damage until
floodwaters recede the only way in and
out of Guerneville is by kayak or canoe
the small town was inundated after the
Russian River overflowed its banks flood
waters surrounded homes submerged cars
and trapped anyone who didn't leave
right here this is where you park it's
the road
Lord ooh plus ease houses raised but her
basement and yard are completely
underwater have you ever seen anything
like this no more than two dozen towns
along a 25 mile stretch of the river
were evacuated along with Guerneville
Monte Rio is also essentially an island
in nearly a hundred roads in Sonoma
County are closed an area weather
station recorded more than 20 inches of
rain over the past three days in
Greenville at least 2,000 people are
stranded the water came up to the roof
of this RV forcing crews to reach this
man by boat one of at least 40 rescues
in Sonoma County on Wednesday never have
I seen it like this
it's
it's scary but emergency crews are
prioritizing people who are an immediate
danger we're not going to be rescuing
people unless there's an imminent life
safety threat so people are just gonna
have to be patient
Rachael Vasquez didn't think the
floodwaters wouldn't reach her home now
she's waiting out the disaster with her
four kids do you have enough supplies
Sonoma County has urged the governor of
California to declare a state of
emergency as the floodwaters recede more
rain is expected later this week Gail
Meg thank you very much